innovation is really key to to our
industry because life cycles are so
short and so much of the brand building
comes through what's new what's great
what's exciting and we have to foster
that in the workplace so we have to have
an environment that encourages
creativity that encourages some idea
generation so one of the ways to do that
is to really empower designers because
usually a technology company like ours
we focus on rd and we look at what's the
next big thing so it's kind of linear
thinking about we had this last year
what will we have next year the great
advantage for designers is they can
think across different disciplines what
if we take something from here with
something from here what if we look at
the user interface from this category
and put it together with the physical
shape of this category so we've really
empowered designers we've set up design
studios around the world so that we can
tap into local talent and we can also
understand consumer tastes and
preferences around the world and
empowering designers to bring together
some of these discrete insights that
view technology as a building block
technology is not the end goal but
technology is what really facilitates
the consumer experience so that's a
large piece of how we become more
innovative more creative
you